The first step to being buried
alive turned out to be
bribing a cemetery
groundskeeper,
who was insane.
- You out here looking
for zombies?
- Beg your pardon?
- Sometimes we get these meth-
head idiots lookin' for zombies.
- Yeah, no, no, I'm just sad
about a dead person.
- You masturbate on
the tombstones,
make sure you clean up
after your mess.
- Goes without saying.
After that, my intern,
his girlfriend, and I were free
to put our flimsy homemade
coffin anywhere we wanted.
My casket is equipped with an
air tube and a little light.
It is now 1:15 a.m.
At exactly 1:15 a.m. tomorrow,
you will dig me up.
Ugh!
- Rest in peace, Forrest.
- This part's more fun.
- As the sound of dirt piling
atop this coffin grows softer,
I just find myself wanting
to call out,
"Stop! I'm still alive!
Don't go!" You know?
Maybe the only thing more
terrifying than that sound
is gonna be the moment
that it stops.
[shoveling stops]
Yep.
That is more terrifying.
- Bye, Mr. MacNeil.
- Good luck.
- I soon discovered that as
morbid as this was,
and as lonely as it was,
it was mostly horrifically,
oppressively boring.
[snoring]
I slept for a very refreshing
nine hours,
but then I was bored again.
[video game beeping]
I never get to play the games
on my phone, you know.
I'm always so busy, but now--
[phone rings]
Oh! Suzanne.
I had not spoken with my
ex-wife Suzanne since my review
of making our son's
wish come true...
- For mom and me to move in
with Joe Dale, Jr.
- Sadly forced me to convince
her to move in
with her frequently unfaithful
boyfriend,
and now she was calling me.
Perhaps she had finally come
to her senses.
Maybe she was even willing to
give us another chance.
Hey!
How's it going?
- [phone cuts out]
Trouble hearing you.
Are you there?
- Yes, I'm here.
I'm here, what's up?
- Very important news.
So--
- Okay, stop, stop, stop.
All I heard was that you have
important news.
- [garbled]
- I can't hear you.
- I-I'm getting married,
is what I'm trying to tell you.
- Okay.
Far from coming to her senses,
she had now taken full leave
of them.
What could I possibly say
to this horrible news?
Uh, that's great.
- What?
I can't hear you.
- That is great.
Any hope I had ever had
of being with Suzanne again,
of putting our family back
together,
was now shut tighter than this
cheap wooden box.
- Really, really hap--
We're so happy.
[phone beeps]
- Oh.
Before that phone call,
I felt completely
out of my element
in this coffin.
Now, I felt right at home.